moi ce soir je vous parlais d'abeilles
je suis ce qu'on appelle un paysan
urbain un apiculteur urbain je cultive
des abeilles en pleine ville et puis mes
abeilles je vais vous les présenter tout
de suite
voilà mes filles ça c'est les abeilles
neuchâtel vous inquiétez pas le sortent
pas voilà alors voilà quelques images de
paris comment je suis devenu apiculteur
urbain mes parents une maison au
champagne et qu'à l'âge de 15 ans j'ai
planté ma propre vignes et puis avec
mâcon 350 pieds ça produit à peu près
300 400 bouteilles par an donc une
bouteille par jour et bien et puis
ensuite j'ai construit un potager en
permaculture puis un arboretum avec des
variétés d'arbres avec un thème sur les
terrains dire c'est à dire que c'est
vers toute l'année puis à l'automne ça
explose de rouge et d'autres couleurs et
puis je me suis dit naturellement 1
il faut installer une ruche quoi donc
voici ma première ruche en champagne et
voici et là ma première capture dessin
donc tout de suite je me suis passionné
ont une ruche de ruches trois ruches
une fois qu'on est piquée ben on peut
plus s'arrêter et puis je me suis dit
mais pourquoi pas l'installer à paris
parce que je poursuivais mes études de
philosophie à paris et donc le 1er avril
2008 j'ai écrit au gouverneur militaire
de paris en lui demandant de participer
à ma démarche d'installation de
d'abeilles en ville au plus tard pas de
réponse j'ai appel
et puis là le secrétaire me dit mais
attendez c'était pas un officier qui
nous faisait une blague parce qu en fait
oui j'avais envoyé mon courrier le 1er
avril
et voilà hasard du calendrier y avait
pris pour un fou
et puis on discute on discute et puis
finalement il ne dit pas pourquoi c'est
sympa donc une ruche de ruches trois
ruches puisse demande à l'école
militaire qui accepte aussi magnifique
vue sur la tour eiffel
et puis ensuite le musée d'orsay puis ça
continue cette année avec le ministère
de l'intérieur etc etc
voilà une jolie photo avec la mascotte
le chien apiculteurs donc voilà ça
c'était mes abeilles parisienne aux
cornes
les vues des invalides et puis j'ai
commencé à produire je me suis dit il
faut distinguer de tout ce qu'on fait
déjà
je me suis dit il faut faire quelque
chose de très exclusif parce que c'est
paris je vais numéroter les pots à la
main comme font les grands crus de
bordeaux les grands vins de bourgogne
donc cesser de produire un miel tout à
fait unique et exclusif
chaque poète unique l'autre chose c'est
que les fleurs parisienne sont des
fleurs exotiques
on a du sophora du japon du tilleul de
crimée et magna
c'est ce qui fait que le goût est aussi
unique
il a un goût très rouge de cassis avec
une finale en menthol serbielle qu'on
peut pas trafiqué trois choses que
j'aimerais que vous retenez ce soir trop
chiffres c'est que 80% des espèces
végétales dans le monde dépendent des
pollinisateurs leur survie leur
production la deuxième chose c'est qu'on
perd chaque année une ruche sur trois
c'est épouvantable
imaginez un paysan qui perd une loge sur
trois chaque hiver la dernière chose
c'est que 40% de ce qu'on mange de
l'alimentation mondiale dépend
directement des pollinisateurs dont le
principal et l'abeille mellifère alors
les causes sont multiples
multifactorielles j'en parlerai un peu
plus tard mais principalement c'est la
désertification des campagnes les
pesticides et les invasif voici un joli
sont de colza ans est magnifique ça
pleure ça floride
dix jours de semaine ça fait du miel les
abeilles vivent dedans évidemment mais
au bout de deux semaines la période
c'est un désert biologique il ya plus
une fleur ça c'est le terroir
idéal pour des abeilles c'est dire que
vous avez des arbres partout des fleurs
des champs les aides qui permettent aux
abeilles de se nourrir
tout au long de l'année avec les
floraisons successives voilà encore une
image de terroir ça c'est un exemple pub
est donc canton de neuchâtel on avait le
petit oiseau qui s'appelle le pdh
écorcheur madeleine disparue
pourquoi parce que les paysans arrache
les ai depuis 50 ans donc ce petit
oiseau a disparu c'est un oiseau
qu'amusant tout ce qui le cultivent des
femmes dit il attrape des propylées les
piques sur les barbelés au sur les
épines
mais on ne verra plus dans le canton à
moins que ils seront réintroduits
s'assembler c'est super beau 6 1
mais je vous défie de trouver des fleurs
dans un champ de blé depuis 50 ans
environ
à vous de dire eh oui on peut trouver
des coquelicots oui notre 2/3 du liseron
si le paysan va pas complètement gaz et
son sol voilà j'en blessé un des abbés
logique je reviens à mon champ de colza
d'accord il fleurit d'accord il fait du
miel est le problème c'est qu'il est
bourré de pesticides qui que ce soit
exposé son chant que ça soit des graines
directement robes et bien des ogm
principalement les néonicotinoïdes c'est
ce qui abîme énormément nos colonies
d'abeilles c'est donc voilà je parle de
la toxicité
c'est pas pour rien que le monsieur il
se protège en partie prépare les
produits voilà une jolie forêt aussi si
une forêt cultivée en sylviculture
régulière donc c'est tout la même espèce
du même âge bah y'a pas de fleurs vous
me direz il ya peut-être du miel a pas
faire du miel 2000 et l'a peut-être
certaines années mais ya pas de fleurs
pourquoi est ce que la lumière ne vient
pas jusqu'au sol puis vous n'avez pas
une anémone rien du tout les forêts sont
intéressantes pour les abeilles
si elles sont utilisées en sylviculture
irrégulière c'est à dire de toutes les
espèces de tous les âges ensuite je vais
venir aux vins vasif homo problèmes
autres que connaissent les abers depuis
une vingtaine d'années et un petit
acarien qui est arrivée d'asie
c'est l'équivalent d'un lapin qui vous
suce 62 ans de près et puis c'est lui
qui fait s'effondrer les colonies
d'abeilles en fin d'été chaque début
d'hiver les abeilles et asiatiques co
évolué que cet acarien depuis des
centaines de millions d'années centaines
de milliers en tout cas elles savent
c'est booster le retirer et nos abeilles
européenne ne le savent pas voilà encore
une gros plan d'un acarien en train de
ne pas résister son hôte directement sur
la larve
et puis une fois que la carrière à
percer l'exosquelette de la bei même si
la laisse en vie et bien elle n'a pas
d'autres défenses immunitaires que ce
fameux exosquelette donc tous les virus
rentre ensuite dans son corps le frelon
asiatique
il n'est pas encore arrivé en suisse
mais ça va venir il vient d'arriver à
paris
il était signalée l'année dernière en
banlieue proche donc que cette année on
va s'y coller il a suffi d'une seule
reines fécondées dans une dans un
conteneur en provenance de chine
nous tenons les poteries en choquera que
c'était au début des années 2000 une
seule reines fécondées toute l'europe
est envahi
alors nous on connaît bien le frelon
commun le frelon européen qui est un
régulateur d'espèces alors que le frelon
asiatique est beaucoup plus agressif
c'est vraiment invasif 3,4 frelons en
vol stationnaire devant une ruche
suffisent à stress assez gentille et sa
merci
3-4 frelons vol stationnaire permanent
devant la ruche vont tellement l'a
stressé que les abeilles sortent plus ne
font plus de miel et la ruche est
quasiment condamné les abeilles asiatica
puis serena
elles connaissent la ruse elle laisse
rentrer un frelon dans la ruche elles
reculent en recul elle le laisse rentrer
puis quand il est bien entré lui tombe
dessus
et puis elles vont faire une forme de
boule de chaleur et le tuer par
hyperthermie parce que le frelon
supporte jusqu'à 40 degrés avec la bei
cependant jusqu'à 42 mais la bei
européenne ne connaît pas la ruse et
puis on ne peut pas lui apprendre de
génération ans est une co évolution sur
des centaines de milliers d epuis la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que ce petit
cette petite bête charmante vient
d'arriver en europe dans le sud de
l'italie
c'est un petit coléoptère africains qui
vient donc d'afrique du sud et puis une
fois qu'il rentre dans la ruche pas ils
commencent à la parasiter manger le miel
et puis pompe ses larves
petit à petit la ruche avait
complètement pourri donc ça y est elle
est en italie donc il va petit à petit
probablement remonter par tourner en
europe
je vous passe aussi tous les virus lock
up and american tous tous ces virus qui
sont notamment transporté par 20 voix
une fois qu'il a percé le squelette de
la bei et maintenant je vais vous parler
de mon expérience suisse je suis arrivé
en 2011 en suisse pour travailler dans
l'horlogerie puis bout d'un an et demi
je me suis dit que ma passion c'était
pas les montres c'était vraiment
abeilles je vous ai parlé des parasites
des pesticides de la diverses la
diversité florale qui étaient
complètement perdus dans les campagnes
et bien en milieu urbain
y'a pas de pesticides ou très très peu
on trouve un peu sur les balcons mais
c'est pas ça qui va faire les miellés
beaucoup intéressé les abeilles en ville
à temps plein il faut penser à un arbre
de la même manière
donc pas de pesticides et surtout
énormément de floraison normale en temps
commence en février sur le romarin et
puis on va se poursuivre poursuit
ensuite les tilleuls les érables jusqu'à
novembre sur le lierre moi ce que je
sais c'est que champagne je fais 20 kg
par an et par ruche à paris il monte à
60 puis à paris je perds pas michael
o'neill j'en ai perdu 0 cette année
alors construit jaune et perdurer donc
là on est sur le toit du beau rivage à
neuchâtel qu'est ce que je fais en
suisse avec mes abeilles je me suis dit
tout simplement il faut développer ce
concept qui fonctionne les colonies
survie venus en ville pourquoi pas
lancer le dans cette histoire en suisse
donc citizen mise c'est une entreprise
éco-responsable qui a pour objectif de
favoriser la survie de l'abeille en
installant des colonies en ville sur les
toits des entreprises ou collectivités
et donc une entreprise fortement engagé
dans le développement durable et la
relocalisation de l'économie
pourquoi parce qu'on importe environ la
moitié du miel d'europe de l'est et de
chine moi ce que je veux c'est faire
travailler des apiculteurs locaux avec
une production du miel local et une
empreinte carbone quasi zéro
donc qu'est-ce que je fais j'ai installé
des ruches sur les toits entreprises ça
permet de produire le miel pour
l'entreprise est de faire un projet
vivant avec les employés de l'entreprise
avec les clients c'est à dire c'est pas
je vous pose des ruches sur le toit puis
je reviens en septembre avec le miel et
puis voilà non c'est à dire qu'il ya
vraiment un projet vivant d'intégration
avec les employés je dirais que les
maîtres mots c'est la sensibilisation et
la pédagogie
lorsque le sujet est passionnant mais
deux les urbains sont grande demande de
grande demande
de nature tout simplement la deuxième
chose je me suis dit que font les
grandes boîtes tout le monde sera un
jour installé des ruches sur un toit il
faut je me distingue d'emblée comme font
les grandes boîtes elle connecte les
frigidaires les lunettes connecte les
appartements oui mais il faut connecter
la ruche
donc c'est ce que je suis en train de
faire je voudrais développer un
prototype de ruches qui permet d'avoir
une visibilité sur votre ruche en temps
réel grâce à des dizaines de webcams de
capteurs thermiques cartographie la
ruche de balance de bain mousse
réapprendre le système indépendant
capteurs de force donc d'hygrométrie
intérieur/extérieur température sens du
vent etc
toutes ces données collectées permettent
d'abord de tenir les délais apiculteurs
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de se déplacer
tout les tous les trois jours sur les
rouges pour voir ce qui se passe bien il
sait ce qui se passe à distance s'il ya
une miley qui démarre au contraire 617
parce qu'il pleut elle remet en jeu leur
miel 6-1 et sacchi ça aurait peut être
prévenue automatiquement par un texto
sur son attelle générer des alertes etc
2e 2e dans l'application c'est pour le
monde scientifique
le monde scientifique pour avancer a
besoin de grandes quantités de données
avec une batterie de rushton autorise
partout en suisse c'est bien peu
commencé à collecter des données
statistiques se demander pourquoi survie
venus en ville et pas la campagne est ce
que c'est les pesticides ou est ce que
c'est les ondes électromagnétiques et
c'est avec beaucoup de données on peut
commencer à comprendre pourquoi ces
abeilles disparaissent donc applications
scientifiques et la troisième
application c'est une application qui
permet tout simplement une entreprise ou
à ses employés d'avoir sur écran géant
dans son hall ou bien dans une cafétéria
et bien de voir ce qui se passe sur
leurs toits et puis comprendre que ba
aujourd'hui l'on fasse françois g de
miel puis le lendemain un kilo c'est ça
c'est le cerveau du système qui peut
accueillir une centaine de capteurs et
puis personnellement pacifie aussi actif
donc si je dois fermer une porte ont
déclenché un traitement à distance c'est
possible donc le champ d'application est
très très large la troisième chose qu'on
peut utiliser la bei comme stations de
mesure de l'air et du sol et de l'eau
aux alentours la bei va à trois
kilomètres autour sa ruche
non je bois une centaine de litres d'eau
par an donc l analyse elles prélèvent
des échantillons via l'air elle prélève
des échantillons de poussière aussi et
puis vient les fleurs les échantillons
de sol ce qu'on peut faire c'est
prélever du sang de l'hémolymphe
l'abeille et puis analyser tout ça un
laboratoire pour comprendre ce qui se
passe et repérer les polluants
environnementaux
parce que dans le miel ne retrouve rien
en fait vous demandent souvent mais à
paris le miel doit être pollué plein de
landen banon l'abeille filtre son
environnement dans son corps on retrouve
un peu de traces dans la cire quasiment
rien au miel mais surtout dans le corps
de la bei elle même est la quatrième
chose c'est que l'on parle beaucoup de
l'abeille mellifère mais il n'ya pas que
la lia des centaines peut-être 400 ou
500 espèces d'abeilles et solitaire en
suisse notamment les bourdons les eaux
soumis et atteint donc je fais ce que je
construis des des hôtels à insectes qui
permettent de leur donner le gîte le
couvert et ans autour on sait les fleurs
mais on trouve plus de vieux bois qui
qui qui permet d'accueillir l'exil aux
sages les les os mais l'effort véhicules
etc
donc c'est important aussi de ne pas
uniquement agir pour l'abeille mellifère
mais aussi avec les autres
pollinisateurs donc bourdon aux mini
état pour conclure moi j'ai envie d'être
au centre d'un cercle vertueux trois
parties mon objectif c'est de faire
vivre les apiculteurs c'est un métier
très difficile on dit qu'il faut 300 à
400 ruches pour environ puis si peu tous
les thébains fait pas de mal et puis
vous vivez pas puis l'été suivant vous
perdez faire l'hiver suivant vous perdez
encore un tir de vaulruz le deuxième
gagnant c'est l'abeille tout simplement
plus de russes et plus d'abeilles
la bei dans votre disparition donc plus
d'apiculteurs plus de ruches plus
d'abeilles le milieu d'un temps
favorable je les dis le troisième
gagnant c'est l'entreprise ses employés
qui rakic qui gagne à mieux connaître
les insectes à être sensibilisés puis
tout simplement recevoir le miel qui est
fait par leurs protégés au dessus de
leur tête
je vous remercie beaucoup pour votre
attention